hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the ancient schools of philosophy
indeed a whole philosophical movement
that michelle foucault devotes a
considerable amount of attention to
in technologies of the self is that
of stoicism and from the very beginning
we should say a few things
he's not talking about the stoic
movement
per se he's mostly interested in
and focusing on what we typically call
late stoicism
or imperial roman stoicism
typically we divide stoicism into the
early stoa with
xeno and the first several skull arcs
and then we have middle
stoicism with peneteus and posidonius
and some of the people around them
although there's a continuation of old
stoicism they're they're criticizing
those those figures as being unorthodox
and then we have the late stoicism
of you know for example seneca
mussonius rufus marcus aurelius
epictetus
various other figures as well and much
of the literature that we have the
direct literature
is from those those later stoics
there's a lot of you know debate and
controversy within the
scholarly literature about how much
divergence there is between them
foucault he's really putting that
question aside he's just interested
at least in this respect in what we're
going to get
from you know seneca onward as a matter
of fact he discusses cicero but doesn't
worry about cicero's
representations and depictions of stoic
cicero was able to actually study with
with some of the
leading stoics of the time so we're
getting a kind of partial picture
and we're also getting a picture of the
stoics that
suits foucault's narrative it's largely
true
you could say but there are some gaps in
it that i'll point out
as we go along so he tells us that in
the roman imperial period
stoicism as an approach is changing
and he gives us a couple examples of
this he says there's a different
conception of truth and memory another
method of examining the self that's
that's particularly important
first we see the disappearance of
dialogue and the increasing importance
of a new
pedagogical relationship a new
pedagogical game
where the master teacher speaks and does
not ask questions
and the disciple does not answer but
must listen
and keep silent and then he shifts to
talking about you know
pythagorean and plutarch not stoics
right so so that's a little bit
irrelevant there
and so here's one of the places where we
can say
based on what we actually have
is foucault largely correct
is foucault really overstating things is
foucault 100
correct it's guaranteed he's not 100
correct all you've got to do is
read epictetus as discourses and you'll
find in them some dialogues
including dialogues not just with
students but with
people from around town a guy who's got
a sick child
a roman pure pro-curator all sorts of
discussions like that so
let's say that foucault is largely
correct about this there's a
shifting away from direct dialogue
perhaps
and more of a focus on you know
monological
you know here's what we need to study
that's already there though say in
cicero's
on the ends where cato gives this long
speech about the nature
of stoicism before they go on to you
know criticize
some of those stoic doctrines so this
master speaks student listens thing
that's a part of stoic teaching as far
as we can tell
but it certainly isn't the totality of
it
so if we go on a little bit further um
there's this discussion about
seneca and the examination
of conscience in seneca's day era
he describes an examination of
conscience
the goal is the purification of the
conscience using a monomic device
do good things have a good examination
of the self a good sleep follows
seneca doesn't just talk about this in
day era of course he talks about it at a
number of different points in his works
and this is indeed a stomach practice
the
notion that at night um and actually you
might also at the beginning of the day
do some things we see this in marcus
aurelius and
epictetus as well but at night you you
go over
how the day went and whether you did a
good job or
did a poor job and and you think about
you know sort of an after
action report what went wrong how can i
do better the next
day foucault makes an interesting point
he tells us
that seneca is using using
juridical language and it seems that the
self is both the judge
and the accused but if you look closer
seneca is using terms related not to
juridical but administrative practices
as when a comptroller looks at the books
or a building inspector examines a
building
self-examination is taking stock i think
this is a really great insight
and i think he's quite correct about
this that the
self-examination is not just like you
did the wrong
thing it's more like okay uh
the building's not up to code somebody
put the plumbing in wrong we're gonna
have to undo the plumbing
um what what happened here right and why
is this a bad
bad thing so i i think he's actually
quite correct about that
and i would say that that fits in with
the stoic perspective in general when
you look at the stock taking
that marcus himself is urging
and that epictetus is also suggesting we
ought to do i think it jibes perfectly
well with that it's not just about
some imperious judge they've broken the
rules it's more like how do you fix
what's what's wrong with the building
that is yourself or the process
that is yourself so false he says there
are simply good intentions left undone
the rule is a means of doing something
correctly not judging what happened in
the past
and he says seneca is a permanent
administrator of himself not a
judge of his past and so there is
a a sort of um
you know different attitude towards this
than what we're going to see later in
christianity for example
there's also this discussion of um
retiring into the self
and why do you do this well it can be to
get away from all the crap that's
outside in the world
it but it's not just supposed to be like
a little
pleasure trip inside your your memory
palace or something like that
he he frames it a different way the
stoic spiritualized the notion of honor
horace's the retreat of an army
the hiding of an escaped slave from its
master or the retreat into the country
away from the towns
as in marcus aurelius's country retreat
a retreat into the country becomes a
spiritual retreat into one's self
it's a general attitude a precise act
every day
you retire into the self to discover
not to discover faults and deep feelings
but only to remember rules of action the
main
laws of behavior it is a as he says uh
memo technical um uh
sort of thing to do i think foucault is
overplaying this
i think that you do there's several
motives for retiring into yourself
that are there in the stoic literature
some of it is to
you know retire into yourself epictetus
tells you you have got citadels within
yourself that the vices have created
you need to break those down right so
you do that by retiring into yourself
that's clearly a different motive the
memorization of things the recalling to
mind that's definitely a motif
that foucault is pointing out sometimes
you do retreat into yourself
so that you can put off the stuff that
is is troubling you
another key thing that he singles out
and he talks about a little bit earlier
in the work
is letters to friends and now this is
not a just
just stoic thing but he does point out
some interesting features
of these these letters that are
happening in this this period
right he says that if you look at for
example
cicero's letters here we go you can
compare cicero to the later seneca
or marcus aurelius in this this field
of writing right attention is paid to
nuances of life mood reading the
experience of the self was intensified
and widened by this virtue of the act of
writing
so he says we see seneca and marcus's
meticulous concern with the details
of daily life with the movements of the
spirit with self-analysis
everything in the imperial period is
present in in marcus
uh aurelius's letter to fronto he talks
about all these
different things and he says the letter
presents a description of everyday life
all the details of taking care of
oneself are here the care of the self
right
all the unimportant things he has done
cicero tells only important things
but in aurelius's letter these details
are important because
they are you what you thought what you
felt so
there's an important transformation in
epistolary
exchange you could say going on
and in some respects letters are
becoming a little bit more like what
lyric poetry had been centuries before
this is a technology of the self for the
stoics that the stoics are making
big use of you could also think of
marcus aurelius's own
meditations to myself as
similar being similarly being writings
like that
you could think about epictetus as
discourses which he himself did not
write
but were written down by his
pupil and disciple aryan
as another example of this writing
seneca's own writings
as well so we've got two really key
things letters
and the this stock taking this retreat
into oneself
going on at this point foucault says
something
that's uh reminds me of when
in aristotle's nico mckay and ethics he
tells us
that there's two kinds of particular
justice and then goes on to detail
three kinds of particular justice
foucault is actually doing
the opposite of this he says uh here we
go
um this is after that section i have
spoken of three stoic technologies of
the self
letters to friends and disclosure of
self examination of self and conscience
including a review of done of what
should have been done in
comparison of the two so that's only two
and maybe the retiring into the self is
the third one there then he says now i
want to consider the
third stoic technique escasis not a
disclosure of the secret self but
a remembering right and so
this this third one is what he devotes
probably the most time to
and is is foucault strictly correct
in how he's interpreting the term
escasis in the stoic text
no i wouldn't say so but it's
it's it's you know good it's revealing
some stuff to us
and it's kind of helpful there's a bit
more to i think
the term escapist than what he's doing
with it but
that's okay let's see what he's actually
saying so he tells us
it's not a disclosure of the secret self
but a remembering
for plato one must discover the truth
that is within one if you remember your
platonic dialogues the truth is within
us we
we know things from having been in a
previous life we just need to have it
brought to mind
stomachs don't have that right there's
no pre-existence of the souls
you know in some previous life and
transmigration or anything like that
stoics are materialist as a matter of
fact the soul probably dies
with the body except in very rare cases
for for the stoics
so he tells us in the stoics truth is
not in oneself
and we're going to come back to that in
a moment but in the logoe
the teachings of the masters one
memorizes what one has heard converting
the statement one hears
into rules of conduct the
subjectivization of truth is the aim of
these techniques now
is this completely correct no
so if we're mapping it on to the stoics
is it an interesting
and revealing way of talking about it
yes so
for the stoics truth is not in oneself
that's incorrect
that that's correct in the sense that
it's not in you
in a platonic sense but part of the goal
of stoicism as a philosophical movement
is to assimilate that truth to yourself
so the truth eventually does
end up being within yourself there's
already a good bit of truth within
yourself
you just have to sort of disentangle it
right there are for example
the as epictetus calls them the
prolapses the
general ideas also called the anoi
in other places general ideas that were
were born
with us innate ideas so you know
uh foucault is being a little bit shifty
here uh for his own purposes i guess
um the logoy are the logo the teachings
of the masters
sure but this is also passing over the
entire
meaning of the term logos
the singular of logoi the entire
universe is permeated by a logo it's a
divine
mind that we call zeus right and within
each of us there is a spark of that this
is just straight out epictetus
um and that is the you know the the
logie k
uh part of ourselves the rational part
we all have
logos within us so it's it's a matter of
using logos to have more
logos you could say to strip away make
your logos work
properly so you know is it just the
teachings of the masters
where did they get their their ideas
from right that that's a problem there
so
this can't be a adequate treatment of it
of what ascasis is but it is it is
revealing you do learn from masters
you do assimilate what it is that they
have to say their logoy
which are about the logos and which
activate your own logos
so that's you know it's not completely
wrong
a little bit later he says something a
little bit better that i i
like quite a bit he calls eschesis
which we can translate as discipline
training
whatever we want practices um
here we go a set of practices by which
one can acquire
assimilate and transform truth into a
permanent principle
of action alethea truth becomes
ethos you know that is uh character
it is a process of the intensification
of
subjectivity okay i think that's dead on
that's a really great way
to describe what goes on in escasis
you're not just doing exercises just to
do exercises you're not just doing them
because somebody said this is good for
you
there should be this continual process
of
you know acquiring assimilating and
transforming truth
into a permanent principle of action
um he also talks about this quite
rightly as
getting prepared para skelos literally
to equip yourself
right so that that's correct and then
foucault
then you know says oh well they broke
these down into two
parts this is kind of interesting
because it parallels
uh plato's own discussion of of this
sort of thing
in republic uh book two where you
contrast music
and gymnastica right so melete
and gymnasia um this is not a bad way
of representing things and it's kind of
schematic but it's interesting as well
it says what are the principal features
of ascasis they include exercises in
which the subject puts himself in a
situation where he can
verify whether he can confront events
and use the discourses with which he's
armed that's
gymnasia it's a question of testing the
preparation right
then there's the actual like preparation
so he says the greeks characterize the
two poles of these
exercises by the terms melete and
gimnasia
melete means meditation according to the
latin translation
metatatio it has the same root as it's
quite correct about this
as epi malaysia it's a vague term a
technical term borrowed from
rhetoric melody is the work one
undertakes in order to prepare a
discourse or an improvisation
by thinking over useful terms and
arguments it's a matter of anticipating
the real situation
through dialogue in one's thoughts and
so there if you look at the stoic
literature there is a lot of this right
there's a lot of giving you advice about
how you should think about situations
that you're not yet in and how you can
like frame
things for yourself to better understand
it that is indeed a significant part
of stoic literature and he brings up the
pray matatsu malorum thinking about bad
things before they
or even if they don't happen
in order to equip yourself against them
and
actually let's take a little close look
at what he has to say about this he says
the most famous exercise of meditation
is this pre-meditation malorum is
practiced by the stoics
it's an ethical imaginary experience
in appearance it's a rather dark and
pessimistic view of the future
the stoics developed three eidetic
reductions of future misfortune
so it's not a question of imagining the
future as it's likely to turn up but to
imagine the worst that can happen
even if there's little chance it will
turn out that way right
second you don't envision things as
possibly taking place in the distant
future but as ac
already actual in the process of taking
place that's how you're visualizing it
so don't imagine you might be exiled but
imagine you're already exiled
don't imagine for example that you're
old imagine yourself as being old right
now
right and then the third he says is
you don't do this in order to experience
inarticulate sufferings but in order to
convince yourself they're not real ills
there's an
ethical component a you know aesthetic
component to this you you think about
your you know eventual death
as like being right here so that you
won't fear death so that you won't see
death
as an evil and this is a great example
right so there's lots of
exercises like this you can do this with
rejection you know worries about public
speaking
you can do this with anger right and
then there's gymnasium
gimnasia is the training yourself by
placing yourself
in real life situations where you have
to use the teachings the rules
the truth that you've assimilated and
try it out right
so if it's uh public speaking that
you're worried about and you did some
you know pray meditation
malorum for that now you actually go and
give a talk
and you you apply the things that you've
learned and in the process you're doing
two things one is
you're actually doing it and and you
know
reinforcing the habit by doing it but
the other thing is you're verifying
yourself you're verifying whether you've
managed to
not just cognitively but
actually assimilate these these
principles
right so that you can make it happen
and you know th this is quite true there
there's a lot of this with the
uh stoix he also says that you know
processes of abstinence you know for
example
sexual abstinence physical privation
other rituals of purification epictetus
for example councils
you know on a hot day take a sip of
water
let it be in your mouth spit it out
don't swallow it don't
you know do some voluntary privation
that's going to make you better and he
says
what's the point of this it's not um
purification or witnessing demonic force
as in the pythagoras and socrates in the
culture of the stoics their function is
to establish and
test the independence of the individual
with regard to the external world
right so here's a prime example that he
gives
um seneca is letters he prepares for a
great feast day by acts of mortification
of the flesh in order to convince
himself poverty is not an evil
and that he can endure it right then
foucault says that there is a whole
other range of stuff
in between these two poles of melete and
gimnasia intermediate
possibilities and he gives us an example
of this
watchfulness over representations so
watchfulness you could also call this
attentiveness is how it's translated or
even mindfulness right
prosocce paying attention to what's
going on
but representations is a bad translation
usually in the stoic literature we we
translate this as
appearances or impressions fantasia
right uh the things that present
themselves to us it might be true or
might be not
so we are the creatures that can make
rational use of that according to the
stoics and there's all sorts of
exercises
and discourses about how to do this
properly he gives two metaphors
from epictetus the night watchman the
money changer these are just two out of
many that that epictetus actually uses
um and he actually says something kind
of kind of um
funny about epictetus here that i think
is is um
worth noting he tells us in epictetus
there are two exercises sophistical and
ethical
the statistical ones are exercises
borrowed from the school question and
answer games
this must be an ethical game that isn't
much must teach a moral lesson
the second are ambulatory exercises in
the morning you go for a walk and you
test your reactions to that walk
the purpose of both exercises is control
of representations not the deciphering
of
of truth this is completely wrong
because
epictetus talks about truth all the time
and
so the notion that this is just about
action or something
it's a it's a misreading of epictetus
and and there are
a number of other kinds of exercises
that we see besides just what foucault
is calling here the statistical and
ethical those are you know that's not
how epictetus describes them
those are classes of exercises but we
see in epictetus discourses and then
caridian
a lot more going on right so we want to
be a little bit careful in buying
foucault's story the the last thing he
talks about
and it's kind of funny he brings it up
as a
fourth technology of the self or you
know
whatever we want to call these practices
is dream interpretation
and he tells us that
um here we go in additional letters
examination anasthesis
we must now evoke a fourth technique in
the examination of the self the
interpretation of dreams
and he tells us that quite rightly most
stoics are critical and skeptical about
some
such interpretation but there's still
the popular and general practice
of it there were some experts which
included some of the stoics and some
people wrote books about this
but it's it's not really among the
technologies of the self that the stoics
as the stoics are embracing so you
wonder why
he's bringing it up in that section
maybe it's just to be you know as as
comprehensive as he can be
these are really the the most important
things the scasist
all these different practices that are
going on
writing including writing letters but
also writing to yourself
and the stock taking that's going on
whether written
or whether carried out within one's own
mind it was supplemented by the
retreater retiring into the self to
remember the rules of actions
so this is the way that for code depicts
the
stoic development of technologies of the
self
in order to foster the care of the self
you